نحن جاهزون للفنجان ، لذلك ربما يكون هذا
أحد أكثر الأشياء إثارة التي يجب علينا
القيام بها هنا
هو أن نتذوق ونشتم كيف
تعمل قهوتنا
وهو نوع من نبضات قلب
العمل بأكمله ،
فنجان القهوة المفضل لدي هو بالتأكيد
فنجان قهوة مصنوع بنوايا حسنة
يمكن أن يأتي كقهوة عربية ، ويمكن أن يأتي
كقهوة تركية
يأتي كل منها بعد من يأتي من
هذا الكوب المفضل لدي ،
يعتبره البعض
عاصمة القهوة الأولى في العالم حيث المقاهي منذ قرون
ازدهرت حيث أن
أماكن التجمع في الأحياء ،
تعد القهوة صناعة قديمة هنا في مصر ،
لكن القهوة المتخصصة جديدة
جدًا إنها عصرية جدًا ولكننا لا نتطلع
إلى أن نكون عصريين ، فنحن نتطلع إلى أن نكون
خالدين
وكان من الصعب حقًا علينا
العثور على قهوة ممتازة  مساحة القهوة
وقد فجر علينا للتو لماذا
لا نجعل هذه المساحة
في مركزها الأساسي للقهوة في القاهرة هي خدمة
اشتراك توفر حزم
تحميص وتوزع القهوة
على المنازل والمحلات التجارية.  في جميع أنحاء منطقة
العاصمة ، سمح النجاح المبكر للشركة
لهم بفتح مقهى ، كما
أن جزءًا كبيرًا من رحلتنا هنا في
مصر كان
يحاول إنشاء لغة مشتركة
لبناء ثقافة لشاربي القهوة ،
ولا يتعلق الأمر بالقهوة ، بل
رحلة  رحلة النبات من المزرعة
إلى التحميص هذه الرحلة بأكملها إذا
بدأت بنية حسنة
حتى تنشر الخير في جميع
أنحاء العالم ،
كان القهوة شيئًا شعرنا
بشغف تجاهه ويلبي
معايير الجودة
والتميز التي كانت
أه القاهرة  معروفين بأننا جميعًا
نشارك هذه الرؤية المشتركة القائلة بأن القهوة
هي فرصة
استثنائية وربما يمكننا تشجيع
الآخرين على رؤية
الأشياء غير العادية وشيء آخر في
حياتهم وهذا نوعًا
ما هو الدافع وراء الأعمال التجارية
لماذا نفعل ما  نحن نفعل